hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art it makes
it competitive our wheelhouse is usually
movies some TV but today it's going to
run the gamut through just about every
artistic expression one could possibly
claim because on this here episode we
got Queen Latifah taking on Jennifer
Lopez obviously they won't be appearing
here in studio that would be awesome and
they're both invited whenever they'd
like to take a tour and maybe get to see
the Jeep from Jurassic Park or Harley
Quinn's bat we got some cool stuff here
but it all panels in comparison to the
incredible output from both JLo and
queen that's been happening since the
1990s Living Single and Living Color and
that was only the beginning for two of
the most acclaimed and diverse careers
Hollywood has ever seen and today
they're both on the show again not
literally it feels like I'm gonna have
to remind folks of that throughout this
video essay but again the invitation
always on the table if they'd like to
say come in studio and meet Wilson the
volleyball he's around here somewhere
the poor guy gets lost sometimes well
done
well done I also pointed out that
there's not actual competition that I'm
aware of between Latifah and Lopez it's
just that this show is called versus and
we like to celebrate all-time great
resumes like the ones these ladies Sport
and continue to nourish by making it a
little tet.tech film is going to be the
primary focus here but we can also spice
things up with music TV behind the
scenes stuff Charities these two icons
do it all but only one can win the most
prestigious prize in all of this
particular area winning an episode of
versus I'm Mark Ellis they're Legends
and here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score round three
iconic characters round four memorable
moments and then we'll do a Wild Card
round that could involve anything from
music videos to dance moves to magazine
covers apparently people still read
magazines I'm reminded of this every
time I go to the airport I'll still grab
a rolling stone for the flight and
there's a very good chance I'll be
skimming through some blurb about a
Queen Latifah project or a new JLo
Venture see look really wanted to be
here today but they're just too busy in
one corner we got Jennifer Lopez who got
started as a Fly Girl on a Living Color
before making it big in music TV and
film in the other corner it's Queen
Latifah who became well known on the TV
and music scenes first and then would go
on to star in Big Time movies as well
they can both bust blocks with their
monikers on a poster fill our ears with
emotion and even appear in our living
rooms if that's where your TV is or you
can stream them on your phone it's Jetty
From the Block and queen they're
omnipresent and it's high time we honor
their legacies by declaring one a winner
you're both Victor's in my book but for
the sake of this show we'll make it feel
sporty by exclaiming Let's Get It On
round one box office ah the movies
there's nothing quite like heading out
to the multiplex getting a big bucket of
corn extra butter for me but it's okay
because the sodas on a diet and watching
the screen light up regardless of what
genre of the film you're seeing is you
got a good shot that Jennifer Lopez and
or Queen Latifah are involved and if
they weren't I'll bet at least one of
them was seen during the previews which
we now call trailers for some reason and
it still bugs me the green screen says
The Following preview I'm gonna call it
a preview
no one will know what I'm talking about
Good see that's your problem you tried
too hard hey remember 2019 Jennifer
Lopez was in a pretty big movie I was
even getting Oscar buzz thanks to
Hustlers which held in 150 million
dollars worldwide yet that's not even in
her top six flicks in terms of cash
registered you remember Valentine's Day
the holidays sure you probably
celebrated it with flowers or forgetting
to get flowers or maybe you're like man
you buy a Russell Stover Heart full of
chocolates and eat it all by yourself
what the dog can't have chocolates more
for me vide is also a movie featuring
Queen Latifah that Charmed up 217
million dollars across the globe yet
it's not even in her top six Buck
earners of all time we knew they were
a-listers but wow is today going to be a
scrap Jennifer Lopez had her film
starring coming out party thanks to
don't say out of sight we're not there
yet I was thinking 1997's Anaconda
starring her ice cube a hilarious Jon
Voight and rumor has it there's a giant
snake as well it would amass 136 million
dollars and even before that her turn is
Robin Williams's teacher what and Jack
helped grow that total to almost 60
million dollars ooh and she's great in
1995's Money Train alongside the best
two-man basketball team in movie history
the take lived up to the title as it
turned out 77 million dollars that out
of sight happened in 98 her and George
Clooney had unparalleled chemistry and
it matched money trains run tracking to
77 million dollars but that wasn't Jay's
highest growing movie that year she
appeared in vocal form in ants which
farmed 150 two million dollars if it's
voicing animated fair you like I'll keep
yapping J willow also contributed to Ice
Age continental Drift which made 879
million dollars in 2012 and also starred
Queen Latifah so she gets that Doe on
her scorecard as well and might have a
leg up because the queen was in three
other Ice Age flicks as well Collision
Course the Meltdown and dawn of the
Dinosaurs if you can tell any of those
movies apart you're a better viewer than
I or much much younger but they dominate
the box office the Latifah ones alone
have garnered over 2.5 billion dollars
and I will admit I do find the squirrel
funny
foreign
also has Chicago and its 306 million
dollar take and hairspray in its 202
million dollar hold under her belt while
projects like The Bone Collector Scary
Movie 3 and bring it down the house all
raked in over 150 million dollars girls
trip was just below that line at 140
million dollars and remains one of the
hardest laugh fests I've ever had at the
movies JLo ain't done yet though she can
counter with Holmes 385 million dollar
draw and Monster-in-Law made Manhattan
and shall we dance all earned at least
150 million bucks each okay so remember
when I said JLo broke out in Money Train
or ants whatever it was let's all
remember the first time most of us saw
JLo and shouted that's a star it's when
she was playing another famed musician
Selena the 1997 movie generated 35
million dollars in box office but well
over a hundred billion dollars in terms
of emotion heart and influence if she
started that movie today that's an Oscar
win for her bar none but the last word
in round one goes to the queen who
helped headline Barbershop 2 to 60
million dollars last holiday to 43
million dollars and remember before
Jimmy Fallon hosted The Tonight Show but
after his SNL Heyday he made a movie
with Queen Latifah called taxi which
hailed 68 million bucks in 2004. some
highlights some also rants but so much
of the coin these films generated is
thanks directly to the contributions of
JL and ql but who has the might to win
the first point of the day let's go to
the law of averages Jennifer Lopez and
her many films have teamed up to snare
3.1 billion dollars which makes for an
impressive average of 107 million
dollars per movie anytime your average
take is in the triple Millions uh you're
doing something and likely many things
right Ken Queen top it Latifah has a
cube of 5.2 billion wow and her per film
usual is a robust 141 million dollars
and sure both have tossed in some
animated works that help bolster those
numbers but I'll remind you that these
digits are gaudy even without the help
of a huge comic book property or an
outer space franchise you got a lot of
rom-coms some Thrillers a few snakes
tossed in good filmographies great
results and our result for round one is
a point for Queen Latifah who taught me
how to spell the word Unity
Queen one Jennifer nothing as we head to
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score okay so we loved both these ladies
as we walked into the movie theater and
that's not even mentioning all the TV
ratings the streams the downloads the
views and CD sales yeah CDs remember
compact discs they came in Jewel box
cases yet for some reason they were
packed in a long weird cardboard boxes
it was a strange time ask your
grandparents we're fans of Latifah and
Lopez and at the bo that was good for
over eight billion dollars combined but
now we're in round two which asks the
query what did critics and audiences
think about your movies as they exited
we get to kick things off with a good
old hustle contest you the home viewer
don't have to run anywhere but you may
recall that Queen Latifah star's
opposite Adam Sandler in Hustle and that
JLo is in Hustlers which one fared
better on the Tomato Meter Hustlers is
at 87 percent fresh but hustle is 93
it's an early lead for the queen and she
gets to brag about more movies first
hair sprays at 92 percent Chicago's 86
percent and girls town is 85 percent not
to be confused with girls trip which is
even fresher tied with Aqua Net at 92
percent meanwhile Jade to the low has
out of sight at 94 in the veggie patch
ants at 92 percent and an early roll in
1995's mi familia which rested 79
percent Selena is 67 percent don't worry
we did an episode of my podcast Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong on that very movie and
all of us including special guest Harvey
Gan agreed that that movie should be way
higher up you're welcome planet Earth
where's Anaconda come on it's got to be
95 96 right 40 percent but it's the jaws
of the Amazon it also unfortunately
brings up a great Point these ladies may
be as fresh as they get but lots of
their movies didn't quite get up to that
60 percent necessary to be a fresh film
number there's some rottenness about
these filmographies so let's put the
gloves on and get this over with damn it
who put money train at 22 percent all
right the Tomato Meter is a
representation of how a wide swath of
critics felt but I bet the audiences
loved it Wesley Woody JLo come on it's
at 29 of the audience score it's an
improvement it's all right you know just
a little bit too much testosterone in
here both Jack and the wedding planner
are just 17 the boy next door is 12 and
the film her and queen share Ice Age CD
that's continental drift not compact
disc thud's at 37 percent the problem
for Latifah is that she's got lots more
Ice Age on her IMDb would a penalizer in
the tomato garden well you got the
Meltdown which damn near made it to
Fresh at 57 percent they also have
Collision Course which landed at 18 so
that's a wash how about that Taxi movie
we talked about ooh deer nine percent e
Joyful Noise hit the 32 percent note
what happens in Vegas catches 25 percent
and beauty shop primes with 38 I'm sure
audiences have been kinder to some of
these movies right yeah last holiday
goes from 55 on the TM them to 67
percent with the audience and even dawn
of the Dinosaurs Roars into fresh
territory at 62 percent okay
talk him out meanwhile continental drift
is 61 of the audience score that's a win
for both divas and a nice segue into how
Lopez fares here the backup plan leaps
up to 46 percent and Monster-in-Law
scared up 55 with the audience oh and
remember enough where she trades and
ultimately beats the crap out of her
abusive lover great movie it was only 22
percent of the Tomato Meter but the
audience score knew what's up and it's
fresh there at 67 percent so it seems
like we got a pretty even battle here oh
uh oh I forgot to mention one of the
most famous flops of recent decades
geely it was no Jersey girl which came
out rather quickly after Julie it also
starred benefit that being JLo and Ben
Affleck they rekindled something
recently did I read that in US Weekly
it's also a magazine romances breakups
makeups all that hot gossip side I'll
pay attention to it I do pay attention
to the Tomato Meter and Jersey Girls 43
percent there and Julia is six percent
yikes Jersey girl's pretty good though
George Carlin shows up
to go black are better than you those
men are not your uncles oh no no we're
good enough to build sets for a show
right I got it sorry I mean that to the
wall of averages we go once again and
Jennifer Lopez Sports a Tomato Meter
average of 42 percent but an audience
score of 53 percent okay so we're
competing Here Comes The Queen Latifah
averages 45 of the Tomato Meter and
seals the win with a fresh 60 according
to the audience and just like that qwell
gets the round two point it goes up two
to nothing on recent Super Bowl Halftime
performer Jennifer Lopez cold you might
just get along
round three iconic character I can't
figure out what's more incredible how
iconic each one of these women has
become in just about every facet of
entertainment there is or that they're
still so capable of slipping into other
characters and making us almost
completely forget we're watching someone
that famous act or sing or write or
produce their resumes are stacked
meanwhile I have nothing but a nap
planned after this taping just looking
at Lopez and Latifah's career
accomplishments is actually exhausting
for me born Dana Lane Owens now known as
Queen Latifah she's played many other
names in her day and more than a few
stand out such as Cleo one of the
central characters in set it off this is
still one of Latifah's most recognized
roles mainly because it's signaled an
official and proven turn from hip-hop
artist to movie star with some very
important TV along the way more on that
in a bit we'll also get to JLo's TV
moments but I'll kick her off in round
three with Selena the biopic that
arrived in theaters a year after set it
off once fictional the other a real life
Tejano star who had her life tragically
cut short not too long before the movie
was filmed but both helped establish
that one fly girl and that all hail the
queen musician as hyphenates that could
do anything in entertainment and do it
well JLo began her performing career as
a dancer on the pivotal early 1990s
sketch show In Living Color which helped
launch the careers of folks like David
Alan Grier Jim Carrey and lots of
talented funny people with the last name
Wayans around the same time Latifah had
moved on from Tommy Boy to Motown
records and released her Black Rain
album which took the charts and the
Music World by storm while Lopez was
making the transition from background
performer to Silver Screen star in the
mid 90s with Tifa booked a role on
Living Single a show that centered
around a bunch of Single 20-somethings
Living in New York sound familiar it
debuted before friends but like the
Central Perk show it would become one of
the most influential sitcoms of the
entire decade and for all the credit we
give JLo for her performance as Selena
and rightfully so Queen also played a
music legend in her career the film was
Bessie about the mythical but very real
1920s blues singer Bessie Smith the turn
would see a sag award and an Emmy
nomination head the Queen's way speaking
of awards I hear them Academy of ones
are a pretty big deal and queen was
nominated for her mama Morton role in
Chicago Latifah also paved the way for
actresses of all kinds to star in a
rom-com thanks to trailblazing Fair Lake
last holiday you no longer had to look
like Meg Ryan or Julia Roberts till we
had a successful romantic comedy that's
fine with me baby
also showed command of an audience early
in her career Selena and Anaconda opened
within weeks of each other and both were
number one at the box office their
respective weekends once you get
Typecast as Selena or a snake Hunter out
of sight arrived soon thereafter and one
could argue that she helped George
Clooney figure out this whole big screen
thing remember he was mainly the guy
from ER unless you're a hardcore Facts
of Life fan which I was and M rom-com
Parts like made in Manhattan and The
Wedding Planner showed JLo as a lead not
just the most prominent female and even
when lesser material like the boy next
door showed up she provided a spark in
every scene more recently Lopez appears
to have become ageless and is
effervescent as always just see her
performance in Hustlers a role which
many pundits felt was snubbed come Oscar
time both Lopez in shades of blue and
Latifah in shows like The Equalizer have
shown that they can come back to their
TV roots with success and seeing Queen
at a motherly tenderness to the NBA
Centric hustle hints that she's
beginning to tap into yet another
Splendid phase of her career but if most
things are equal in this round all about
the characters you inhabit I gotta lean
with JLo and the tie breaker might be
Selena she actually performed as the
Fallen icon in front of over 30 000 fans
for the film and to hear accounts of the
folks in attendance it was like she
became Selena afterwards she got off
stage Selena's mom gave her a big hug
and the emotion was real and in much
less exciting news the win is real for
JLo in this round she's on the board and
cuts the lead to just one you wanted to
tussle we tussled
round four memorable moments okay so
let's continue the Selena love here did
I ever tell you about the time she
performed in front of over thirty
thousand oh right I just did I love that
story it counts here too but we'll move
on because it is gonna make me cry both
ladies find their footing easily and ROM
comes there's a real cute moment in The
Wedding Planner when JLo saved from a
runaway garbage bin just in the nick of
time by Matthew McConaughey and then
asks why are you still on top of me it's
fun and I'm still waiting to meet the
love of my life like that get off the
dating apps boys start hanging around
loose garbage bins why are you still on
top of me made Manhattan is Big On
Emotion while marry me with Owen Wilson
feature some Superstar concert sequences
and the warm maple syrup sweetness of
the marriage is worth a shot talk but if
we're talking all out great comedic
moments and that's probably what this
round is about it's kind of how you win
I need the floor to gush about girls
trip that entire movie is why I always
say see comedies in theaters opening
weekend fantastic crowd The Joint was
packed my tummy was sore from laughing
too hard the dance battle the lady Mouse
scene it's the best that flick is
probably the top 10 hardest laughers
I've ever seen but then you have Chicago
and her legendary performance of the
tune when you're good to Mama Sly
references giant fans it's good stuff
and as if Latifah wasn't herself good
enough see Joyful Noise at how great of
a time she has with Dolly Parton
infallible Untouchable
unlovables Edward Scissorhands J-Lo
bursts on the scene as a stealer of them
from either a huge invertebrate with
anaconda or a handsome vertebrate with
George Clooney out of sight I caught
this movie recently again and that
bathtub sequence still steams up the
entire screen I forgot how awesome the
jailbreak sequence is and her deadbeat
kinda boyfriend is you guessed it
Michael Keaton the cell is worth
revisiting for killer visuals and trippy
psychedelic moments that have us
doubting our very existence it may not
be the Matrix but it shouldn't be
forgotten either he always finds me like
every round thus far we see a tight race
coming down to the wire how does one
break the tie between the pole dancing
and fur coat dining of hustlers against
the phenomenal woman take in beauty shop
I might have to say enough's enough and
consult the movie Enough JLo shows way
more range than that Tomato Meter score
indicates she can go subservient
delicate frightened but then morph into
a courageous Alpha badass and sometimes
we see all those colors within one take
I still remember seeing the trailer
excuse me preview for that film in a
packed theater the premise gets set up
we know this dude's an abusive Deuce we
feel sorry for her and then he comes
home and boom JLo oh in the foreground
gloves ready to kick ass the whole
theater went ooh that's good stuff you
marry that with Selena snake hunting
rom-com Mastery and once again Lopez
emerges with a win here in round four
and suddenly we're tied two to two
[Music]
girls
and finally we get to put it all in the
line and let's factor in some more TV
music icon like stuff that both Queen
Latifah and Jennifer Lopez seem to pull
off with stunning regularity and have
for a very long time obviously both are
Trailblazers that have carved a path for
artists from all walks of life to follow
and they began this road forging
remarkably early in their lives Queen
Latifah became the first female rapper
to take over Hollywood making an
immediate impact with cameos in jungle
fever and house party 2. but she was
also assigned to one major record label
at that time and showed off her
survivalist Ways by transitioning to an
even bigger music career with Motown
records nominated for an Academy Award
in the early 2000s and earning a star on
the Walk of Fame in the mid-2000s were
certainly benchmarks of success but I
attribute a sizable piece of her Legacy
to Living Single up to that point TV
audiences had only seen a handful of
shows like a different world and Martin
as a modern take of people of color
making their way in the world as opposed
to already being established with
careers and families Living Single Maybe
the ladies the primary focus and he
didn't have to be a supermodel to feel
represented watching it the series was a
big ratings earner for Fox and when we
talk nowadays about projects like girls
trip getting the green light and
generating hundreds of millions of
dollars it's fair to say movies like
that can run because Living Single
walked
[Applause]
part of JLo's appeal will always be
intertwined with her breakout role as
Selena but not just because she
portrayed such a legendary performer
through embodying the Tejano star Jake
Lowe gave us a sneak peek at everything
she dazzled us with for decades to come
singing dancing acting romance Thrills
heartbreak the whole gamut of human
experience was on display and she was
just getting started to still dominate
the headlines and not just the tabloids
after all this time is a credit to her
versatility where she can open a huge
movie and have a monster album drop
around the same time in 2001 her record
JLo featuring an Ellis family favorite
love don't cost a thing was number one
on the charts at the same time the
wedding planner was top at the box
office and her fashion line was just
getting started as well spearheaded by
flamboyant appearances at award shows
when she was always walking the line
between classy and head turner for Lopez
to still be primarily known for her
artistic achievements rather than just
being famous at this point that is
enough to sway me towards her in the
Legacy round but as both of these women
continue forging career milestones and
breaking new ground this is a
conversation that we will continually
revisit JLo gets the Wild Card win for
now and thus takes the match three to
two
after all these years and then all of a
sudden bang that's how it is but you're
both winners the world of entertainment
will be a much more boring place without
its queen or Jenny From the Block you're
both Victor's in my book and you're
invited to the studio to look at um we
have a hoverboard here too I think come
anytime you want except right now
because I'm signing off and I have a nap
to take now it's up to you dear viewer
hit us up on social media at Rotten
Tomatoes and head over to
rottentomatoes.com for all the latest in
the world of movies TV and anything else
Queen Latifah and Jennifer Lopez might
be up to until then I'm Mark Ellis
thanks for watching versus and in the
words or rather letters of a great
artist uni
[Music]
[Applause]